Hello and welcome, everybody.
This is physics as information processing.
It's October 28, 2023, and we're in discussion 6, so we'll see where and how and when we go.
But to begin with, thank you for watching.
If you're watching live, please feel free to write any questions or comments in the live chat.
As this is our last discussion, we're going to be probably ranging broadly, so looking forward to people's comments there.
Otherwise, perhaps we can all go around first and say hello or just give any thoughts or reflections to get things going.
And then we'll jump into some of the questions and answers and look at some of these great thoughts that have been sent and responded to.
So perhaps Dean and then Harrison, David, any just overall thoughts or comments to get us going?
Thanks.
Daniel.
I guess my overall impression was that I think that the way that the entire series was organized and structured allowed for these kinds of conversations that we're having today, which I think are really valuable.
As you can see on the slide here, I think a lot of question and answer tends to be focused around "what is," whereas the conversations that we've had, we can sort of tease that apart a little bit and ask questions around "what if?"
And get into the counterfactual piece of it and interact around that.
And I've really, really appreciated that, so that's my overall sense that we haven't left it sort of on the page.
We've actually been able to sort of breathe some life into it through these conversations.
Cool.
Haris?
Yeah, I just wanted to say that it was a great series.
We all learned a lot, and we got the opportunity to even ask questions to Chris and get back some very insightful answers that they are very helpful in order to, let's say, push the envelope forward.
Overall, this has been a great series.
I've enjoyed it a lot.
And while conversing with some of my colleagues, they also enjoyed it.
So the feedback is great.
And thanks to active Inference Institute for facilitating this, and to you guys.
Thank you.
ThanK you and welcome.
David, if you want to just begin with, any thoughts or what brought you into the game in the bottom of the night?
Well, in school, I was actually trying to use free energy to develop some sort of a network of agents that were deciding what information to send and what states to be in based on each other's approximation of each other's states.
So I registered at the beginning, but then I guess life happened and I didn't really cross the page.
Now I'm just kind of opening up to things and participating more in the world that I exist in.
And this is a natural.
This is really tied to the work that I was doing in school.
I don't know if this is a place to ask a question, so I'm not going to ask any questions.
Let's begin with that.
Okay.
Yeah, so I was thinking about.
I'm still confused about like Markov blankets and non- localism.
How would those two work together?
Well, like, nonlocalism, seems to me that an entity could be distributed arbitrarily in whatever is.
I don't know if the universe is like spacetime is what is, or if that's just a construction that we create through the information processing and putting relation, enunciating or rendering the information in a way where it's like all the related components can be mutually distinguished.
But the Markov blanket seems to be highly local.
I don't know, maybe this is what, like, I'm confused about this.
It seems to be highly local, and it seems like everything is connected with everything.
So I'm kind of confused about how an entity could be defined with a Markov blanket while at the same time what seems to be completely intertwined, nonlocal, mutually defined.
Yes, Dean, please.
So can I just, David, just clarification.
Are you thinking that local and nonlocal is somehow similar to maybe arbitrary?
I'm thinking local is within a volume and nonlocal is distributed like a sphere, like a small sphere, where all the information is within a sphere and everything within that sphere is causally relevant and everything without is causally irrelevant.
But then when I'm thinking of a Markov blanket as a sphere and everything on the inside is like independent statistically from everything on the outside.
I guess I'm asking around, where do you see that being placed?
Do you see that being placed arbitrarily?
When you set that up, whenever you decide where that boundary exists, are you asking because it's local or it's nonlocal because it's wherever inside and outside is present?
Is the...what's the word I'm looking for?
Are you wondering about how that doesn't seem to be consistent, that in one minute it can be here and then the next minute it can change and arbitrarily end up being in a different place?
It doesn't seem to me that that's the confusion.
It's more like, you know, David Bohm's implicate and explicate order and the idea that the explicate order is like one hologram.
There's the holo movement where each layer affects each layer and the explicate is all at once explicate order, mutual relatedness.
I don't know if these words are incoherent completely. But then the Markov blanket, like, I'm taking the example of my skin.
I don't know if that's even a good example, but my skin is like a Markov blanket.
But then if everything is mutually related in explicate order, this whole body is submerged in the same field that everything else is submerged in.
And in that sense, everything is linked to everything.
Let me try adding a few pieces.
So welcome.
Ander and Chris will hopefully join, too.
Here we go.
Okay, opening act.
Just to catch up, Chris and Ander. David asked about the Markov blanket and about, if/how everything is connected to everything and how we associate Markov blanket or the holographic screen with localism and nonlocality.
Do you want to give any quick thoughts on this, or are you asking.
Me if you want to?
Either of you could.
I don't know.
Let's wait a minute for Chris to show up.
Yeah, I'm here now.
Yeah, I'm glad you found the way.
Did you guys go through the slides of last time, the lecture on biology.
No, no.
We just began and started with a Markov blanket question.
Yeah, I think you wouldn't hurt to talk about that, because a big part of that last lecture was the copy and diversify notion as a universal feature in nature, and naively, I think the creation of new boundaries is implicit in there.
So maybe Chris can comment, but I also thought it was very worthy of mentioning today, the cycle of error correction, memory and so on.
So those would be my only two comments in the agenda for today.
Maybe Chris can say a few words, but I didn't mean to interrupt.
So, Markov Blanket, we can pivot it to biology, I'm sure.
Okay, I think I'm seeing this question.
Is this a question about the definition of Markov blankets?
There's something about...I can't actually see the entire.
No, it's not a question on my screen.
Oh, it's not a question on your screen.
Right.
But could you tell me what the question is again?
Yeah, David, just restate it how you see it.
Well, the question was if everything is mutually connected and mutually defined and interconnected, and there's nonlocalism in the sense that everything is mutually connected and mutually defined...and I'm kind of implicitly working with the assumption that the implicate-explicate order makes sense, and the explicate is, like one hologram.
And it's lost audio altogether now.
Oh, I still hear him.
Oh, the audio.
Chris.
Yeah, I lost at least half of that audio; just dropped out altogether.
Try to.
Sorry about that.
If everything is kind of explicated, like, if it's information in the brain is kind of rendering it all at once together, I'm just confused, and the whole body is submerged in it.
If I look in the mirror, the whole body is submerged in it, and it's all nonlocal.
By that, I mean it's all connected together and mutually defined and mutually necessary to even make sense of any piece of it--if there is even such a thing as a piece.
So that's one way of looking at it.
And then the other way is, what's local to me, it seems like there's, the skin Markov blanket, and it's kind of local.
And I'm kind of confused as to how those things work.
It seems like all the information in a sphere, a sphere could be a Markov blanket.
And then on the inside and the outside, they're statistically independent, is that the whole movement on the inside and the outside, because of the Markov blanket, separates those.
But then if this whole body is submerged in this thing that's mutually related.
I don't know.
I'm confused as to how those things work together.
I'm not sure I understand your question, but I suspect the answer has to do with whose point of view we're talking about.
So, if you are the system that's in...so let's fix a Markov blanket someplace.
If you're the system on the inside, then all you can see is what's encoded on the blanket, and you have no independent access to what the dynamic says on the outside.
So you don't actually know what the dynamics is on the outside.
And similarly, if you're on the outside. Now, if you're somehow able to view the whole system, you can see the whole system as having some joint dynamics.
But if the whole system is isolated, then there isn't anybody on the outside, kind of by definition.
So the idea of a whole dynamics is just a theoretical postulate that we make to make the mathematics make sense.
Now, if you move from the classical formulation to the quantum formulation, then it's possible to prove a very nice theorem, which is that if you're inside a holographic screen, you can't measure the entanglement entropy across the screen.
What that means is that you can't know that your state is conditionally independent of what's going on outside.
So if you're inside a holographic screen, you can't know that you're not entangled with whatever's outside.
So you can't even know whether you have a well-defined state in a sense.
I think the same thing would probably hold true from the point of view inside a Markov blanket, that you wouldn't be able to know whether your Markov blanket had holes in it or something like that.
The problem is, in the classical formulation, you assume there's no analog of entanglement.
So there's no analog of entanglement entropy.
So I think the strongest thing you can say is you don't actually know your statistical relationship to what's going on outside, but you still can only see what's encoded on the blanket.
Thank you, Chris.
If I could add a few more pieces.
So, David, you described everything connected to everything.
For a system with that kind of a base graph, there aren't Markov blankets, because a Markov blanket is the set of nodes that make two other sets of nodes conditionally independent.
So in a fully connected setting, again leading to the question, what is outside of that?
But in a fully connected setting, you don't have a blanket as such.
In fact, the Bayesian graph describes the factorization, or the articulation and the sparsity of the system.
So it is a connectedness that is usually much, much sparser than everything connected to everything.
But that's not to say that differences can't make a difference at a distance.
It's just that they propagate through a local causal structure.
And then spacetime is constructed by certain kinds of cognitive agents; that was one of the key aspects of this course.
And so we can take as primary the topology of the active inference agent-environment relation.
And then Markov blanket is just the sensorium on the inbound and the action capacity on the outbound.
One question, though, I do have to that is, what about the nonzero gravitational effect, for example, of something that's distant in space and time?
Of course, Markov blankets don't have to be spatio-temporal.
They can be in arbitrary state spaces.
But how do we deal with those kinds of long range influences?
That's my question.
Yeah.
Well, here I think it's useful to contrast Newtonian gravity with Einsteinian gravity.
Newtonian gravity is infinite range and instantaneously acting, whereas Einsteinian gravity is infinite range, but it's locally encoded.
So the Einsteinian gravity that you feel is your local measurement of the curvature of your local bit of spacetime.
So that is very much happening on your Markov blanket, right?
It's a local measurement, local in spacetime.
So let's assume there's a spacetime that's objective and characterizes everything, then you're locally measuring it on your blanket, and that's what you feel as gravitational attraction or your mass.
Whereas in Newtonian or Laplacian gravity, you don't have that sense of locality, right, as soon as something changes anywhere in the universe, it affects you.
So Einstein was struggling, of course, to make gravity consistent with electromagnetism, where it was clear that forces are transmitted at finite speed, the speed of light.
And he didn't have the idea of a graviton moving at the speed of light, but he did have this idea of local measurement.
So nonlocality was anathema to Einstein, and that's basically why he spent so much trouble removing it from physics.
And that's why he hated the idea of entanglement so much, because it seemed to him that from a spacetime point of view, it had to be nonlocal.
Daniel, can I bring up a point at this point?
So I think this is somewhat relevant to a question I really wanted to ask Chris, which is in lecture 6.
I remember minute 23.
I wish I had written it down, but I can roughly remember there was that phylogenetic graph, and you see life growing in a self-similar way, just like the genealogical tree of species, same thing happens at the individual level with growth and so on.
Anyways, I found that fascinating in the sense that the degrees of freedom, of life as a whole, grow, right, and around that minute 23, you made a comment, well, then the environment must be shrinking.
And you tie this with spacetime, and something about spacetime from the physics side, we also have cosmological inflation and what not.
Are any of those things related?
That remark, I feel like, was made in passing, and I think there's a lot there to be said.
It also maybe shed some light on the emergent spacetime issue.
If it does emerge from a more basic ontological object, like the tensor network and the degrees of freedom in the tensor network, is it fair to say that life, as it grows, gets more of those degrees of freedom, but then somehow anything that happens to spacetime is an illusion in that sense? I don't even know if I'm formulating that question right.
But I think Chris knows what I'm talking about.
Yeah, the comment makes the most sense in the context of the state space itself, leaving aside spacetime.
So if you think of a Hilbert space and draw a boundary someplace that separates what we're going to call life from what we're going to call nonlife.
And essentially, what life has done over the past 3 billion years is incorporate bits of the nonlife part of the state space into life.
Right.
Total biomass is increasing, so more and more of the available mass is getting incorporated into living things.
And so if we can kind of heuristically fold spacetime in and say, "you know, in the locality, in the locale of Earth, and over this fairly short time period, the expansion of spacetime is more or less negligible."
So life is actually taking up more space now than it did certainly at the time of LUCA, when all of us weren't around.
But there is just one probably population of cells that we're descendants of.
But the point about the Hilbert space is just the point that if you've divided it in two and you move the boundary, then one system gets bigger at the expense of the other system, which now has less of the Hilbert space.
So that's all that remark really is.
As the system, in a sense, takes over degrees of freedom of the environment.
In that case, it becomes a different system at every time step from the point of view that it has now a different Hilbert space and different internal dynamics.
So physically it's a different thing.
But when we look at it, we say, "oh, this thing is continuous through time." It's expanding, it's growing, it's developing, evolving, whatever.
Right.
So then, I guess, comment, just a question that just occurred as you were talking, that begs the question, does that biomass come to dominate all the degrees of freedom in the universe?
Is that presumably there's a tension with the rate at which those degrees of freedom are growing and the rate at which spacetime is growing, does the growth of spacetime, in terms of those degrees of freedom that may be more fundamental, amount to loss in error correction capacity?
And maybe more speculatively, how you reconcile this with loss of thermodynamics.
Are you implying that life is going to come to dominate everything and fill up the entirety of the known universe?
Yeah, I think that's a stretch.
But I would say at this point that until we have a mature theory of quantum gravity that makes enough empirical predictions to be testable, it's not clear, at least to me, how the whole emergent spacetime picture fits together with the inflationary picture or the expanding spacetime picture. In some sense, taking a strict Hilbert space view, if the universe is an isolated system, then its Hilbert space is fixed.
And so your question, in a sense, becomes, what's the relationship between spacetime and the Hilbert space?
Are what we think of as spacetime degrees of freedom, real degrees of freedom, or not?
And seems to me that question really isn't resolved, and I'm not sure at this point how to resolve it.
Just have something small to add.
Overall, this is very interesting, and these questions are very deep.
What I wanted to add is what I was thinking about the initial question regarding Markov blanket, and I also have some question that it's related with it.
But I will ask Chris later.
What I wanted to add now is that basically, Markov Blanket are a way of describing the boundaries of a system in terms of statistical mechanics or statistics, let's say, and essentially, from what I understand, they are paramount in order to define observers and also the systems under observation.
So any physical system that can be seen as an observer with a Markov blanket, let's say, so now, trying to tie it all up with active inference.
Well, active inference, as I understand it, it implies that the system is actively referring to its external states from its internal states in an effort to both learn, let's say, and adapt to the environment.
So this goes back and ties with this metaphorical link, let's say, with the skin.
This is how I understand it.
And it actually means that a system with a Markov blanket can actually be seen as performing physics as information processing, which is the book of this series that Chris is offering to us.
And a final comment in terms of nonlocality.
Nonlocality can actually be seen as a form of information processing.
So this is what I wanted to add.
Did you say how nonlocality is a form of information processing?
Yes, this is how I understand it.
What do you think about that, Chris?
If we put it in terms of entanglement, entanglement is a useful resource for information processing, but it's only a usable resource if it's combined with classical communication, either across time or across space.
So entanglement is only useful as a resource if different observers can act locally, i.e., without interfering with each other on the quantum resource.
So if you think of entanglement as nonlocality, if you embed it in spacetime in that way, then it is useful as a computational resource.
But the observers also have to transmit classical communications in a way that fully complies with locality.
So in a Bell/EPR type experiment, for example, if you have Alice in one lab and Bob in the other lab making measurements of some entangled state, then at some point to know that the state is entangled, they have to send their classical records to each other as classical communication and then deal with those records locally.
So in a sense, nonlocality in that sense is useful for computation, but it's only useful if you also have locality.
Great.
Thank you.
Actually, I'm working on a novel notion.
That is something like, takes the notion of entanglement and transform it in the following sense.
I'm actually thinking of maximum unentanglement as a resource for classical computation.
So that's something I am actually exploring.
I find it to be a nice concept.
Did you say maximum unentanglement?
Yes.
Maximum separability?
Yeah.
Okay, that makes sense.
I mean, we need maximum separability.
We need to be able to factor a state space to talk about two different observers.
So to talk about conditional independence.
Yeah.
In my head, this maximum unentanglement as a resource can actually be expended to perform classical computation or even to increase the coherence of a quantum system.
So I'm playing with that notion a bit.
Thank you.
Can I ask one thing really quick about.
Yeah, okay.
So apparently, from what I don't understand very much, but from Bohr, apparently, the whole experimental setup was one entity that couldn't be broken down into constituent pieces that are interacting, but had to be taken as one entity--from what I understand--and apparently Einstein's view was, well, I really don't know what his view was, but apparently it's not one entity; it can be broken down into localized pieces that are interacting.
And apparently they couldn't get along, Bohr, Einstein.
Apparently there was like a party or something, and then they all congregated to separate parts of the room and didn't really interact.
And apparently it was because they had these opposing views on the same thing--breaking down the interconnectedness into separate constituent subsystems.
And even taking the partial trace--there was one universal function taking the partial trace--which [John] Preskill defined...the subsystems, whenever perfectly, it's all tied together, but I can't really explain what I'm trying to say.
These seem like two very opposed view.
They seem like very alternative views.
Like on one side you have kind of an indivisible whole.
On the other side you have locality where it's almost like there's like a sequence of measurements leading up to an ego, an "I" that then measures as like a real entity. Another one is like the observer and the observed are one thing, they cannot be meaningfully separated.
Maybe functionally they can be separated, but as actually existing subcomponents, they cannot be defined strictly.
From what I understand, one of them is saying, yes, you can define these subsystems and they really do exist as separate entities.
The other one is saying, that's just a useful way to organize information, to operate on that information, deposit a subject and an object, and to have the subject operate on the object is a useful way for thinking to separate itself.
And it seems like this is closer to Bohr than the other one is closer...well, apparently that's a distinction of Bohr and Einstein, from what I understand, which is, please correct me if it's wrong.
Yeah, I just wanted to put that out there.
And I don't know what that's going to spawn in terms of responses, but yes.
Well, I think that's a fair characterization of the Bohr-Einstein debate, actually.
To add a response there, whether it actually exists, it seems like in one of those framings, you had an observer looking at something, and if we define actually existing in a relational observed setting, then to the observer the measurement actually exists.
Prepare, measure, prepare, measure.
And then from another perspective, viewing that setup, then it's the observer of a setup.
And so it's just, again, to Chris's first point about what perspective, and this is one of the most essential pieces that the blanket screen relationality brings into play, is there isn't a view from nowhere, but there is a perspective that may have a definite answer, and yet there are multiple perspectives that have complementary answers in our scenario.
Daniel, can I speak for a minute?
Oh, yeah.
I was muted earlier.
I didn't realize.
I meant to ask, David, I don't have an answer to your question, but I was wondering if you could reformulate.
Would it be fair to reformulate your question as saying, are blankets objective or not?
Is the Bohr-Einstein debate equivalent to that?
And then second, and I guess this may be for Chris, I was skimming through the answers, and one of them was talking about how one of the big tensions between general relativity and quantum theory is the idea of object persistence, and I don't know how to articulate it either, but I feel like it was more or less what you were getting at, David, is that correct?
Yeah, I think that's another way to put it.
And also the thing you said about the third person looking at those systems, if there's multi-agent communication, that's kind of the thing that I'm kind of stuck on in terms of trying to understand this, because if there's a third agent looking okay, those two are subsumed in the information on the holographic screen.
I don't know.
Anyways, so that's where I'm kind of...
I think a delightful thing to read here is Eugene Wigner's paper where he introduces the Wigner's Friend thought experiment [1961, Remarks on the Mind-Body Question, Wigner E].
And I think it's from.
There's a book called the Scientist Speculates [1962, The Scientist Speculates: An Anthology of Partly-Baked Ideas, Good, IJ].
The editor is someone named Good.
And Wigner has a paper in this book.
I think it's 1961.
And it's also the paper where Wigner talks about consciousness being an essential concept in quantum theory.
But the thought experiment is that Wigner's Friend is doing an experiment in his laboratory and making observations, and Wigner is outside the laboratory.
And Wigner has to regard his friend as in some sort of superposition with his instrument.
He has to regard his friend as entangled with his friend's instruments until Wigner can actually interact locally with the friend, and make a measurement of the friend's state.
And so it makes Wigner's friend and his apparatus look like an entangled pair.
And Wigner now looks like an experimenter who's operating on just one part of an entangled pair.
But Wigner himself tells the story very nicely.
And that sort of historical text, I think, is always useful to have a look at and see how the people themselves were responding to this idea.
And Wigner is quite perplexed by this thought experiment.
And I think all of those people, they were quite honestly mystified with what observation actually is and what consciousness is.
And all of these other questions that people are a little bit scared to talk about in the ensuing several decades.
Self-reference.
Yeah, you can go ahead.
Self-reference seems to be like there's this ancient symbol of the Uroboros--the output is the input--it feeds on itself.
Even like consciousness.
I have to contextualize...it's self referential.
Everything refers to itself.
And then at the end, self-reference is where all the paradoxes are like, this sentence is false.
Or all I know is that I know nothing.
These are all paradoxical statements.
So there's some sort of mystery, "cell division of self reference."
That ancient view is that it's like embryogenesis, cosmogenesis, same thing.
I don't know.
It seems to me that there's some sort of mystery that's so.
It's like the mind.
It just eludes I don't know.
Thinking tries to make these thought systems, but it just slips out.
I can't grasp it.
I don't mean...but that's already a conclusion, which I don't necessarily want to even make, because if it's self-referenced, that is thinking, OK, then maybe it goes all the way to the bottom.
Daniel, can I ask you a question before we run out of time?
Actually, I have two.
Maybe one is a bit longer, the second one.
So the first one, Chris. I was very intrigued and looking forward to hear you talk a little bit about that cycle of error correction and memory and persistence and so on.
And in particular, I was wondering if it relates at all to the main other thing you talked about in that lecture 6, the copy and diversify business, because intuitively, if that cycle is something that an organism has to implement--I'm talking about that slide with the error correction and what not--then it pays the thermodynamic price for it.
So presumably there is an anabolic process of trying to grow so you can feed degrees of freedom into this error correcting scheme, thinking like a physicist.
Something like that might be happening.
So is the copy and diversify feature a necessity of having to run this cycle?
That's my first question.
That's a good question.
I don't know whether it's necessary.
I think one could think of a fairly small scale heat engine or metabolic system that can pull just enough free energy out of its environment to store a one-bit memory.
And you can think of something like a flip flop, right?
These things aren't alive.
So it's not quite as complex as an organism, but it is using energy to maintain a memory, and its memory does influence its behavior.
So I think we have these limiting cases like this that don't have to grow.
But when you think about organisms, organisms have the problem of being made out of very delicate parts that need to be replaced.
And it's that degradation that I think is driving this need for constant copying.
And from a physics point of view, I think what that boils down to is that the organisms living right at the edge of an interaction with its environment that's too strong to maintain.
So the environmental interaction is constantly at risk of spinning out of control and having too large an energy transfer, which basically tears the Markov blanket apart and exposes too many of the internal degrees of freedom to the outside.
So this may be one way of saying what characterizes life, that it's interacting with its environment right on the edge of an interaction that's too strong.
And it's great to have a strong interaction because then you have big eigenvalues and so you have large bandwidth, but the risk is that the environment tears you apart.
Close to the fire, but don't get burnt.
Become the fire and then control the redox balance and gain that autopoietic regulative capacity, which works when it works.
Yeah.
Until something comes along with bigger teeth.
Another comment, if I may, is, as the course comes to an end, two things I realized associated to classicality that we've talked a lot about in this class are object persistence and boundaries.
Right?
So classicality being a feature, intrinsically boundary related, and having a lot to do with object persistence.
So are just these things completely dual from an FEP point of view, because you want to maintain the integrity of the boundary, you want to preserve that classical information, presumably.
I'm not sure.
I guess my question to everyone is, are object persistence in the topic of classicality...object persistence and boundaries...are these basically completely dual pictures?
That's my question.
Yeah, I wouldn't be surprised.
And we also need object persistence to define space.
So this idea of object persistence is a very key idea that has to be dealt with.
And physics has largely ignored this idea, which is kind of objects are taken for granted.
But I think what Karl [Friston] says in that 2019 "Free Energy Principle for a Particular Physics" paper is fairly clear on this.
He basically says the free energy principle tells systems to persist.
That's basically what a system has to do by maintaining the integrity of its Markov blanket.
I think that's very insightful.
If it doesn't, it's not.
Yeah, it's not a system anymore.
Well, as we somewhat glide towards a local closure, of course anyone is welcome to bring up any reflections.
And also, I'd love to hear about where we go from this now measured outcome.
How do we prepare individually, at the Institute scale, ecosystem scale, and what are we going to do coming out of this?
Are we talking about that right now.
Or any thoughts?
Yeah, keep learning, bro.
What do you mean by the ecosystem scale?
Like the active inference ecosystem and our own ecosystems going on our own scale.
I guess the only thing I can comment on this is I echo the view that, or not view, or rather remark that Chris made in the lecture about quantum biology as a field.
It's in a nascent stage, right?
Mean, I think, you know, there will be a nontrivial interaction between the active inference community and quantum biology.
I'm making that surmise right now.
So let's talk about quantum biology for a second. I'll open up the Pandora's box here.
Let's think of it as a parable as opposed, or maybe even fan fiction, because Chris has shared so much with us, I want to kind of build off of it.
If you will indulge me for a second, I'll read you a little story.
Just hear the story out.
"Quantum biology sounds like more than up or down without saying that it is more. Up or down, as what information can be counterfactually, is looking at carrying capacity as "can be."
And from that carrying capacity comes orientation, things like direction and scale. Things like the ability to plan appear to fit better in the orientation category relative to the carrying capacity category, which is noncommunativity in action."
This is a big "if"--"If we agree that orientation is to follow, should our recognizing of planning affordances follow as well."
"So from the session slide, there was a quote--'Living systems are genetic quantum systems that the FEP has driven to a high level of computational complexity.'
And here the 'computation' is baked in as something planable. With this as a reference frame, to make plans, we need carrying capacity."
"Check. Agreed. But in order to learn where does the carrying capacity plus orientation relationship insist that we start with a received plan?
This perspective is compared to, say, actively inferring our way to the plan, falls out of carrying capacity.
Just making this explicit, we can then ask should we first apply a received plan or apply active inference. That helps clarify when the strategy is one more based on exploitation versus a strategy more based and biased to exploration."
"In summary, when did information delivery things like product or package packaging begin to trump information carrying capacity, which is essentially information processing rather than we need this paired relationship, the carrying capacity plus the orientation, as a minimum of two, so that we can compare, identify change and know change model patterns, etcetera.'
"This is another way of asking when did subject matter expertise come to be seen as more valuable than prediction matter expertise, when it seems like we need both capacities if we want independency."
"And here's the kicker."
"If not given time to reflect on what's being asked here, and I know Chris oftentimes has a nice long pause to reflect...but if not given the time to reflect, people will take their subject matter expertise strategy, which clearly is a next move perspective, over one that holds up 'next move plus all moves,' meaning that they bring prediction matter expertise in to follow, to parameterize, to unlock, to unring, to unbound what's in and what's out."
"Of course, without prediction matter expertise, what is quantum biology?"
Wow.
Can you just post that someplace so we can think about.
I'll just email it to you, Chris.
Cool.
That was great.
Yeah.
I think you're asking about the fundamental question of what does Karl call it?
Epistemic value and the role of curiosity and that whole cluster of issues.
Well, I think I need to give you the credit that you deserve on this.
I think it's the fact that you have allowed us to interact with you that's given us that kind of courage and confidence to be able to put things out there.
I don't know how much of it sticks or how much of it.
I'm not sure that it requires disciples, but I do think it provides.
What you've done is provided that medium.
So again, I guess that's my way of saying thank you.
Well, thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you, Chris.
I have learned so much this year, more than ever before.
Okay, well, great.
This has been a great class, and hopefully various things will come out of it.
Certainly just from looking at the questions that have been in the question forum.
Lots of people are thinking about these issues, and that's what I think AII needs going forward, is people thinking and talking about stuff.
Thank you, Chris. Yeah.
A few outcomes that we know; we'll transcribe the lectures, the discussions, add in screenshots, add in the Q and A, and publish those proceedings as a book.
We will pick back up in 2024 with potentially having the recorded and written contents as part of a curriculum.
So not just replicating, but now continuing on with another quantum flow across this now classical artifact, because it's quantum in the moment, and then once it's communicated, it becomes a classic.
And we have months to prepare that state.
All right, great.
I'm going to have to sign off, but thank you very much.
Thank you, Chris.
Thank you.
Ciao.
Bye.
Does anyone else, does anyone else want to make any reflection or comment?
I just thank everybody that's helped organize, participated in all of the discussions, even the people who showed up at the very end of the discussions, because I really appreciate that.
Again, I cannot emphasize enough, when we get a chance to interact with this stuff, when we get to manipulate it, when we're able to ask questions, even though we feel vulnerable, I think that that's when a lot of the really good stuff tends to get consolidated.
So thank you to all of you.
I'll read some fun comments from the live chat, just the last several, just to recognize some of our great colleagues.
Lucrative leadership wrote, yes.
More on affordances.
Ian wrote, would love for this series to continue.
Joanne wrote, thank you.
This was a wonderful learning experience.
Mills 8102 Two wrote the probable and the possible.
There are some emojis.
Pablo sent a heart pow wow dao.
I don't speak this language, but I can definitely hear, understand, and feel it.
So thank you, everybody who's watching along.
These were all great, and we prepare and measure every day at the institute.
So I really do hope that people from all backgrounds, all vectors, all preference and prior sets come engage and not presuppose too much about us or themselves or what can happen when we really do interact and when we take it into the kinds of spaces and timelines that we know we want to be on.
All right, thank you.
Bye.
Thank you, everyone.